22 juin 1941 le rss entre en guerre ou
plutôt c'est l'allemagne nazie qui
attaquent l'union soviétique à 3h30 du
matin tout le long de la frontière
soviétique qui s'étendait alors de la
mer de barents à la mer noire les postes
frontaliers et les base aérienne
soviétique sont pris pour cible par
l'artillerie et l'aviation allemande
une attaque qui prend l'armée rouge
totalement par surprise
tard dans la nuit du 21 juin je suis
rentré de mon service
la fenêtre de notre chambre était
ouverte elle donnait sur la rivière nous
avons remarqué que sur l'autre rive
la ville était complètement plongés dans
l'obscurité il n'y avait pas une seule
lumière et s'était exceptionnellement
calme le matin vers 4 heures nous avons
été réveillés par les explosions d'obus
lourd et domine nous avons tout de suite
compris que les allemands avaient
commencé une préparation d'artillerie
j'ai crié lève toi mon cher ami c'est la
guerre quelques heures plus tard à midi
le commissaire du peuple
j slave molotov annonce au pays entier
l' attaque allemande par une allocution
à la radio un discours devenu célèbre
qui se termine par les mots suivants
c'est alors le début d'une formidable
mobilisation qui bouleversera le destin
de millions de jeunes soviétique soldats
marins pilotes tous portés vers un
objectif commun faire chuter le nazisme
forte de ses succès sur le front de
l'ouest l'armée nazie utilisera
également la tactique du blitzkrieg et
contre les soviétiques dans l'opération
barbarossa la plus vaste opération
militaire allemande de cette seconde
guerre mondiale
le but de cette guerre éclair faire
tomber l'urss avant l'arrivée de l'hiver
un objectif qui ne sera finalement
jamais atteint et cette date du 22 juin
1941 résonne toujours avec douleur dans
l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui unis d'ici
quelques jours le 22 juin aura lieu
l'anniversaire de l'attak de l'urss par
l'allemagne nazie
après avoir déclenché en 1939 la seconde
guerre mondiale
en attaquant la pologne l'allemagne
nazie a ouvert deux ans plus tard un
autre chapitre terrifiant pour nous les
allemands
cette journée est une source de honte ce
match c'est attaque au lance flammes une
bonne offre un bon vecteur l'allemagne
reconnaît la responsabilité qu'elle
garde pour les crimes du régime neige la
mémoire permanente de ce qui s'est passé
en fait partie cela ne doit pas des
troubles ils nous le devons à 10
millions de victimes et leurs
descendants de cette responsabilité
prend l'origine trou devoir de
travailler pour la paix et l'ordre
international basé sur les règles et
féline frigo
côté russe on célèbre cette date jour du
souvenir et du chagrin qui est aussi une
journée de fierté fierté d'avoir gagné
cette guerre
cette année est marquée par le 80e
anniversaire du début de la grande
guerre patriotique au prix de millions
de victimes du énorme concentration
d'efforts et de ressources les peuples
de l'urss ont joué un rôle décisif dans
l'élimination de la machine de guerre
d'hitler pour sauver l'europe des
horreurs du nazisme
notre devoir sacré et de garder la
mémoire des événements de cette époque
de la transmettre aux générations
futures de protéger l'honneur et la
renommée der libérateur d'un côté comme
de l'autre
la conclusion est la même tout faire
pour tirer les leçons de l'histoire pour
que plus jamais l'humanité n'ait à
revivre ou période aussi sombre